we are here
to celebrate nominees for their
wonderful work in canadian
cinema and television which is a lot
like celebrating
the northern lights you probably haven't
seen them but you've heard they're
amazing
our next presenters are two of the
funniest people in america
she stole the show on saturday night
live then went on to create write and
start her own show
30 rock he was a job in actor
career not going that well if i'm being
totally honest who
who got his big break when i cast him in
a remake
of a show that i created called the
office
he's now leaving that show and killing a
cash cow for both of us
please welcome the wonderful tina fey
and the ungrateful steve carrell
oh julia roberts you live next to me at
the beach you know that thanks for all
the visits
anyway uh i'm living about two blocks
from
the broad never shows up come by and say
hello we're closer than two blocks you
have no lines julie you're just not
anyway i know comics that are very
racist
and i watch them on stage and everyone's
laughing and i'm like
that means that
don't get mad at them don't hate them we
go upstairs and have a beer and
sometimes
i even appreciate the artistry that they
paint their racist opinions with
man it's not that serious the first
amendment is first for a reason
the second amendment is just in case the
first one doesn't work out
our first presenter is beautiful
talented
and jewish apparently mal gibson told me
that he's obsessed
um please welcome
scarlett johansson thank you kevin
uh and now don't thank me thank jesus
i knew it i knew it you know our next
presenter from such films
as hudson hawk look who's talking
mercury rising
color of night fifth element
hearts war please welcome
ashton kutcher's dad bruce willis
and the winner for best community leader
is
jesus sorry i'm sorry
i'm sorry i'm sorry
i got the spirit i'm sorry
yeah the nuggets are having a bad year
this year man matter of fact they're
making a film about the team
they had a pretty catchy title it's uh
black men can't jump either
one hollywood publication said that me
hosting would mean
that some film stars would stay away for
fear of being made fun of
as if film starts to stay away from the
chance of winning a golden globe
particularly if their film company has
already paid for it
tell a friend to tell a friend next
easter steve i want to thank you i want
to thank rashad jesus
[Applause]
you forgot to meet jesus
[Applause]
i was watching last night i saw speed
speed skating
and uh my goodness you know could the
outfits they wear be any tighter
holy lord there was an east german woman
i swear
you could see the outline of her entire
penis it was
and i got to be honest like i don't know
much about writers
you know i used to think you guys were a
bunch of nerds
who couldn't hold up your end of the
conversation you know with
strange shoes
i did lots of big celebrities here
tonight i mean legends
icons yeah look at this table alone uh
al pacino robert de niro
baby yoda oh oh that's that's joe pesci
sorry
um but it's been a wonderful year for
canada
it's been an especially great year for
one little guy
one adorable little canadian youngster
who's already accomplished so much
of course you know who i'm talking about
justin trudeau haven't you had a
wonderful year
talking of the walking dead
congratulations to hugh hefner
who uh is
getting married at the age of 84 to 24
year old beauty crystal harris
um when she was asked why she was
marrying him she said because he lied
about his age
he told me he was 94. oh come on
um don't worry
hold out and just just don't look at it
when you touch it
this is great the oj simpson jury right
there in the front
my gentleman's laughing it's a little
hula the teleprompter is sort of
flashing
oh really because it's a hot show let's
read these funny look
let's let's read these funny lines they
wrote for us okay
talking of all you perverts it was a big
year
it was a big year for pedophile movies
um
surviving r kelly leaving neverland
two popes shut up shut up
i don't care i don't care
and there's charles woodson how about
that i want a season here
great manny he became the first
defensive player to win the heisman
trophy and congratulations charles
that is something that no one can ever
take away from you
unless you kill your wife and a waiter
in which case
i love this next presenter he's so cool
um he's the star of iron man
two girls and a guy wonder boys sorry
these porn films
what kiss kiss bang bang
bow finger really yeah up
the academy come on he has done all
those films but many of you in this room
probably know him best from such
facilities as the betty ford clinic
and los angeles county jail please
welcome robert downey jr
i can't read what's on the teleprompter
black america and white america
there's black americans and there's
white americans we're all one american
so
so if you don't mind this is this is not
live is it
i imagine whatever i say you could just
you could just edit it out let's try it
a few ways lou are you in the booth
i am all right good uh you know what
let's just play around with and see if
we can get it right and get this clip
package on and and then let me go home
all right
all right all right count me in
five four three two
one wu tang i'm just going with you
let's do it again
we're gonna do it again we'll get it
right it was a big year for 3d movies
toy story despicable me tron seems like
everything this year was
three-dimensional
except the characters in the tourist um
i i feel bad about that joke i
no no i tell you why i'm jumping on the
bandwagon because i haven't even seen
the tourist
who has um but no it must be good
because it's nominated so shut up okay
and i'd like to quash this ridiculous
rumor going around
that the only reason the taurus was
nominated was so the hollywood foreign
press could hang out with johnny depp
and angelina jolie
that is that is rubbish that is not the
only reason
they also accepted bribes let's
thank you but i am sorry i cannot in
good conscience accept this award
on behalf of melissa mccarthy i instead
have chosen to give my time to a friend
who has something very important to say
my name is johnny two feathers
while you enjoy tonight's show i want
you to think about something
the spot where you're sitting every
square foot of ground in this country
was stolen from my ancestors and after
you stole it
you murdered them so you'll forgive us
if we do not laugh along there is
nothing funny about the extermination
of a people
the theater stinks of blood that's all i
have to say
oh johnny two feathers everybody johnny
two feathers give away johnny a giant on
a wave all right well johnny two
feathers everybody